you like to push the boundaries in the
ring and you play off your sexuality in
an interesting way it can get quite
saucy that's right and you're quite
filthy I'm gonna you I like the way you
say saucer you know I'm doing it let's
take a look you'll see what I'm talking
about pretty oh my lord
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and a page-turner from the Divas
[Applause]
Champion thank God
[Applause]
I'm not I'm not like a sexual predator
or anything it's mostly I just like to
jerk around and you know sure play it
play jokes on people especially Natalia
so I do I do a lot of stuff with her
I'll lick her face I'll grab a boob you
know because they say she feels really
uncomfortable which is very it's just
quite prudish because it is no I don't
say I know something about when when men
wrestle and I've got a lot of films but
yeah but stuff you can't get any more
but but but I'm just curious about when
when when women are wrestling are there
certain areas that are off-limits you're
like I would think breasts would be
off-limits
I don't know we're very desensitized now
our ladypau is a very different size so
if you know if I get my boob grab down
again it's fine I don't really pay
attention to it I mean I've Hey yeah
thanks good dude that creepy dude in the
front row no no I wouldn't dude in the
front row I wouldn't recommend rip your
face off yeah they were very dissipated
to it like Brie Bella you know does
these yes kicks where I'm on my knees
and she'll kick me across my chest oh my
god and yeah I've had a bruised boob or
two and I'm okay with it yeah I see I do
have a scratch on there right I won't
get out but I do India another scratch
again that's that's your call
[Laughter]
Freed's a salmon that later